hi there um
today i'm in my key quite unusual to sit
in my kit to sit and be in my key my
intention was to do some uh
tidings to the outside but
a small plane decides to pull a glider
if we're near a glider club and it seems
to want to pull a glider or the planes
do
every few minutes and so
i thought i'd come inside because i had
these
thoughts about
some
comments and
questions really i've had lately
even though you don't know the people on
youtube
that uh
write in well i don't you know you can
perhaps go to their youtube site but you
don't really get a full picture on
facebook's a little bit better because
you can click on their page and you know
see see what they
do what they're
getting age
roughly but
but normally from the younger people and
there's not many younger ones out there
nowadays doing aikido sadly but there's
the very young
um who
clubs who teach children
fill them up with masses usually
more like a crash than a
martial arts center
but anyhow i'm digressing
i'd like to talk a bit about what uh
feedback i've been getting on uh
some of my
latest films
does aikido have to evolve was one of
them
um does your aikido work here's another
one
versus humber humber versus walmart
and
all the ones that are asking like
questions what do you think some people
have
quite an aggressive answer
we shouldn't get aggressive about
another person's chosen art
and even if it's an ikea there's so many
styles out there that
you know they might be classed as
different arts going under the name of
aikido
but one keeps coming up
um
maa
bjj i think it's the bjj brazilian jiu
jitsu
anyhow
these two come up more than anything and
it normally is coming up from what i
call the younger
person
who brings in the comments
but the big thing is they're saying that
aikido is out of date and it's old and
it should evolve and it should modernize
if it wants to attract people
so why not add
some maa
fighting skills
bjj fighting skills
into aikido
now there's some teachers out there that
are doing this
they've decided
to add it they may be decided to add it
because
you know they want to
hold the attention of a wider group
they might do it because they feel
genuinely that i could have has a lot of
weaknesses and it needs
some real fighting skills in it
i'll make the list okay it's not
comprehensive list it's
i've been around so long it's
pretty much just straight from my
head i'm just going to read out in no
particular order
what scentsy took
yeah was he a fantastic martial artist
well i think so perhaps some of you
agree with me
but
in the uk here we have a bird called a
magpie that steals things
you know it can steal washing off the
line you can steal anything that shines
like coins or you know
they're known to steal things
so sensei really was a bit of a magpie
wasn't he
i mean the list is endless but there's
just a few
he took things from
dietary
locks pins
quite an aggressive art when you look at
the films of dietary
movements from
naganatha rifle bainit tanto
sword
katana
staff spear
he took japanese arts
the parts he liked from the japanese
arts
not the attacking but
the
uh
development of the manipulation of what
to do
if being attacked
he discovered that it would be better to
work on multiple attack well if he's got
multiple
arts
and ideas why not
he's only got to think about one thing
and that's being attacked he hasn't got
a thing about attacking them
so he's halved the problem
but he also was a bodyguard and he went
to china so he's taking some chinese
arts i know this for a fact with my tai
chi master showing me techniques that
only masters know this what he classed
as secret techniques
one was koshinagi one was shamunuchi
icchio
we'd have classrooms secret
techniques that only masters would
perform or know about
he became very
religious he would every day
pray to the came the gods
he would do chanting
his key eyes could be heard around the
village
they were so loud
a lot of people thought he was a he was
mad
um
he believed in spirits
the sort of spirits that ghosts are
attached to
not the spirit
within you that i talk about
so
do you think really
i mean this is a question would be nice
to hear your answers
do you think really that he needs
that aikido needs anything more adding
it's the youngest martial art
that
out of japan
it's not thousands years the years old
but
what he's taken
the bits from
is
ah i should say
so
perhaps it does need modernizing but if
you haven't got enough in your armory
out of all the things that i've just
spoken about
to defend yourself against somebody in
the street
or multiple attack
psychosis used to say as well as i
sensei
think of one as many and think of many
as one
it was reminded to me by uh my very good
friend miles kessler sensei who i
haven't seen for a long time only on
film
so
the younger people they seem to want
more
and yet the older people say
well are you
prepared to commit to it
you might like watching
maa bjj
on your
youtube channel or
some of you may have even seen it live
but how many will actually study in
practice they don't just get in the ring
and learn a few moves with their arms
and legs
it takes devotion it takes
like a
like olympian
it means many many hours work many hours
of suffering
it's not an easy road
but it's a really enjoyable one yes you
get a few breakages
and sometimes unnecessarily in like you
know
it's never meant to
each other we don't mean to hurt each
other but sometimes it happens
so
this is the question i'm asking you all
i don't personally think that aikido
needs to evolve
because we're evolving
we're evolving by learning and
understanding more
we're understanding more and then we're
going deeper inside ourself
and we change
but so many like
and the masters that have gone before us
and perhaps i will i don't know i try
not to i try to keep the strong basics
because you see i don't have the right
to change the basics
i don't have the right to change a
niccio a shia nagi
i don't
have the right to
halfway through
shia nagi
if there is one
add a piece of mma
you know with my knees or my feet
the beauty
evolves within you
as you do these techniques you're not
doing them well i hope you're not
to go out into the street and show how
good you are or pick a fight just to
test you like you know
yes you hear the stories of the olden
days where people would psycho since he
told me once a story
i won't
tell you it because it was
rather ruthless and
and for many it might put them off
following him
but when you're that good and that
powerful
and
not the mafia there is it but uh
yakuza
or whoever
ask you to do something
perhaps your skills
are there and you cannot say no if you
want to live a peaceful
life
there's always something or someone
greater than you
but for now this film was to talk about
how many things can you add to the list
that i've spoken about
and then ask yourself
why would aikido or oh senses aikido
that none of us have accomplished yet
none of us have reached his height
when i chant i usually do it in my own
room i don't like to think of going out
in this village and chanting people
start thinking i'm crazy
and
stiff stiff upper weapon
being english i shouldn't do things like
that i don't know about your country
but
you know
chanting a hall with other akidoka and
it's great fun
and it's more than great fun it's a
resonance that takes you to another
dimension
religion well that's up to you if you
want to believe in a religion
please uh believe in it and go as deep
as you can
i ask you not to press it upon another
person though
it's your religion
and if they see the fruits in you where
you when you glow
and you become a better person they will
perhaps ask you about that religion
and then start to follow it themselves
these are the wisest words i can give
you
from somebody who's
seen many religions
and don't like any of them because
they've caused too many deaths from me
but that would be starting to get into
politics
if i had to follow a religion perhaps i
would become a buddhist i don't know
but so far i haven't taken the step to
religion but i've taken many other steps
that osensee
showed
so thank you for your time
please
if you wish
contribute to my patreon page
when it says more down below
if you click on that it will tell you
the link
how to get there
where i i go in depth in detail detail
piece by piece
technical information i also do talks
but they're mainly
technical
on the youtube channel here i often
do more
talking than i do technical
but who knows what the future will be
thank you for your time